The really important property of heaps is at the smallest value of all has to be at the top.
Why is that? Because a node can't be below anything larger than that.
The only place that the smallest number can be is at the tippe top.
There may be copies of this number so you might find them at other places.
In fact, the whole tree can consist of 13s, but the smallest one is still at the top.
It may also be other places. The second smallest value can be, maybe immediately below it.
What's the deepest level where you can find the third smallest?
Level I will be here, level 2 is here, level 3, level 4, level 5, and so on.
In this particular example, the third smallest, here's the smallest,
here's the second smallest, and here's the third smallest.
Well, it seem like a natural place for it but can it be any deeper? Write your answer in the box.